there's a lot of different ways that you
can represent a linear equation so for
example if you had the linear equation y
is equal to 2 x plus 3 that's one way to
represent it but i could represent this
in an infinite number of ways i could
let's see i could
subtract 2x from both sides i could
write this as negative 2x
plus y
is equal to 3.
i could
i could manipulate it in ways where i
get it to and i'm not going to do it
right now but this is another way of
writing that same thing y minus 5 is
equal to 2 times x minus 1. you can
actually simplify this and you could get
either this equation here or that
equation up on top these are all
equivalent you can get from one to the
other with logical algebraic operations
so there's an infinite ways to there's
an infinite number of ways to represent
a given linear equation but what i want
to focus on in this video is this
representation in particular
because this one is a very useful
representation of a linear equation and
we'll see in future videos this one and
this one can also be useful depending on
what you are looking for but we're going
to focus on this one and this one right
over here it's often called slope
intercept form
slope
slope intercept form and hopefully in a
few minutes it will be obvious why it is
called slope intercept form and before i
explain that to you let's just try to
graph this thing i'm going to try to
graph it i'm just going to plot some
points here so x comma y and i'm going
to pick some x values where it's easy to
calculate the y values
so maybe the easiest is if x is equal to
0. if x is equal to 0 then 2 times 0 is
0 that term goes away and you're only
left with this term right over here y is
equal to 3
y is equal to 3.
and so if we were to plot this actually
let me start plotting it
so
that is
my y-axis
and let me do the x-axis
so
that can be my x uh that's not
as straight as i would like it
so
that looks pretty good all right that is
my x-axis and let me let me mark off
some hash marks here so this is x equals
1
x equals 2
x equals 3
this is y equals let me do this
y equals 1
y equals 2
y equals 3 and obviously i can keep
going can keep going this would be y is
equal to negative one this would be x is
equal to negative one
negative two
negative three so on and so forth so
this point right over here zero comma
three
this is x is 0 y is 3.
well the point that represents when x is
equal to 0 and y equals 3. this is this
is we're right on the y-axis if there
have a line going through it and this
line contains this point this is going
to be the y-intercept
so one way to think about it the reason
why this is called slope-intercept form
is it's very easy to calculate the
y-intercept the y-intercept here is
going to happen when it's written in
this form it's going to happen when x is
equal to 0 and y is equal to 3. it's
going to be this point right over here
so it's very easy to figure out the
intercept the y-intercept from this form
now you might be saying oh well it says
slope-intercept form it must also be
easy to figure out the slope from this
form and if you made that conclusion you
would be correct and we're about to see
that in a few seconds so let's plot some
more points here and i'm just going to
keep increasing x by 1. so if you
increase x by 1 so we could write that
our delta x our change in x delta greek
letter this triangle's greek letter
delta represents change in change in x
here is 1. we've just increased x by 1.
what's going to be our corresponding
change in y
what's going to be our change in y
so let's see when x is equal to 1 you
have 2 times 1
plus 3
is going to be 5.
so our change in y is going to be 2.
let's do that again let's increase our x
by 1.
change in x is equal to one so then if
we go from if we're going to increase by
one we're gonna go from x equals one to
x equals two well what's our
corresponding change in y
well when x is equal to two two times
two
is four plus three is seven
well our change in y
our change in y is equal to two we went
from five when x went from one to two y
went from five to seven so for every one
that we increase x y is increasing by
two
so for this linear equation our change
in
y over change in x
is always going to be our change in y is
2 when our change in x is 1 or it's
equal to 2 or we could say that our
slope is equal to two and let's just
let's just graph this to make sure that
we we understand this so when x equals
one y is equal to five and actually
we're gonna have to graph five up here
so when x is equal to one y is equal to
and actually this is a little bit higher
this let me clean this up a little bit
so this one let me
erase that a little bit
just like that so that's y is equal to 4
and this is y is equal to 5. so when x
is 1 y is equal to 5. so it's that point
right over there
so our line is going to look you only
need two points to define a line our
line is going to look like
let me do this in this color right over
here our line is going to look like
it is going to look
is going to look something like
is going to look let me see if i can i
didn't draw it completely at scale but
it's going to look something like this
this is the line
this is the line y is equal to two x
plus three and we already figured out
that its slope is equal to two our
change our when our change in x is one
when our change in x is one our change
in y
is two if our change in x was negative
one if our change in x was negative one
our change in y is
negative two and you could see that if
from 0 we went we went down 1 if we went
to negative 1 then what's our y going to
be 2 times negative 1
is
negative 2 plus 3 is 1. so we see that
the point 1 or the point negative 1
comma 1 is on the line as well so the
slope here our change in y or change in
x if we're going from from between any
two points on this line is always going
to be 2.
but where did you see 2 in this original
equation
well you see the 2 right over here and
when you write something in slope
intercept form where you explicitly
solve for y y is equal to some constant
times x to the first power plus some
other constant the second one is going
to be your intercept your y interest or
it's going to be a way to figure out the
y intercept the intercept itself is this
point the point at which the line
intersects the y axis and then this 2 is
going to represent your slope
and that makes sense because every time
you increase x by 1 you're going to
multiply that by 2 so you're going to
increase y
by
2. so this is just a kind of a get get
your feet wet with the idea of slope
intercept form but you'll see at least
for me this is the easiest form for me
to think about what the graph of
something looks like because if you were
given another if you're given another
linear equation let's say y is equal to
negative x
negative x plus two well immediately you
say okay look my y-intercept is going to
be the point zero comma two so i'm gonna
intersect intersect the y-axis right at
that point and then i have a slope of
the coefficient here is really just
negative 1. so i have a slope of
negative 1. so as we increase x by 1
we're going to decrease y by 1.
increase x by 1 you're going to decrease
y by 1. if you increase x by 2 you're
going to decrease y by 2. and so our
line is going to look something like
this let me see if i can draw it
relatively neatly it's going to look
something
it's let me i can do a little bit better
than that
it's my graph paper is hand drawn
it's not ideal but i think you get
you get the point it's going to look
something like that so from slope
intercept form very easy to figure out
what the y-intercept is and very easy to
figure out the slope the slope here
slope here is negative 1 that's this
negative 1 right over here and the
y-intercept
y-intercept
is the point 0
comma two very easy to figure out
because essentially that gave you the
information right there